another thing we should really consider
here is that China is dealing with a
population crisis and they're deciding
to take executive centralized action on
it the United States and the West is
also dealing with the population crisis
and we're encouraging it and saying this
is great we need to save the environment
we need to stop making children and we
even have Elon Musk came up just a few
days ago and said civilization is going
to crumble if people don't have more
children and I believe his warnings are
warranted I think they're true I mean
how how can how can this not be true
right I mean unless we're talking about
some sort of weird meta trans human
future which is which we are
let me just I want to highlight the
article Luke mentioned real quick we
have it from CNBC Elon Musk says
civilization is going to crumble if
people don't have more children the tech
millionaire said low and rapidly
declining birth rates are one of the
biggest risks to civilization I wanna I
wanna I wanna I can sort of provide some
evidence to Elon musk's claim there was
a TED Talk by a guy who tried to make
his own toaster from scratch how much
does a toaster cost at Walmart 20 bucks
10 bucks 10. yeah 10 bucks yeah it's
really cheap you're looking the other
day yeah I just assumed inflation yeah
10 bucks yeah that that means if you
work at McDonald's on average depending
on which city you work in it's probably
gonna take about an hour hour and a half
to get a toaster so this guy decided to
make a toaster himself it's impossible
he discovered it was not possible why he
could not synthesize Plastics
he could make everything else he could
you could Mine The Ore he could smelt it
he could make the wiring he could make
all of that stuff the control mechanisms
but to get the plastic for the outside
of the toaster he had to mine the
plastic which effectively proves it
couldn't be done and the reason I bring
this up in regards to Elon Musk is it
shows the level of specialization among
humans has grown so intense that no
single person can make a thing there's a
um I'm forgetting who wrote the book so
forgive me it's um oh uh Julie Borowski
I think oh yeah was she what did she
write no one knows how to make a pizza
was that herself I think that was her
yeah I hope I'm getting the person right
because if someone else rather than me
mad at me sorry but uh the point of the
book was that cheese pepperoni tomato
sauce the bread no one person can make
all of these things and for the most
part a pizza is not that hard to make
what Elon Musk is basically saying is
and and this is just one part of it with
a declining birth rate one day we're
gonna be like hey who's who's who's
who's there's no food at the supermarket
oh well no one's driving trucks anymore
well who's why not because there's no
one to drive trucks anymore well what
are people doing people are doing other
jobs right now the unemployment the the
amount of people who aren't working is
half the so let me phrase it better
there is twice as many job openings as
people without work the problem is the
people without work don't have the
specialty for those jobs this is what
Elon Musk is talking about we need
Specialties and Specialists to advance
technology and if we don't it doesn't
happen
he's right too and Elon Musk is the one
who says if you want more things you
have to make things which sounds very
profound but when you talk to people who
truly believe that milk grows out of
store shelves you realize that we might
have a problem with conceptualizing
words they do come from they do they do
what they do during the the primary in
in 2019 with Andrew Yang I had people
tweeting at me like I was like if people
aren't no no I'm sorry this was uh I
think it was last year it was 2020 and I
was like if people aren't working to
make milk where will they get milk and
they're like what do you mean the store
and I was like where do you think the
milk comes from at the store and they're
like what are you talking about the
store has milk and I was like wow wow
these people don't understand the
concept of the supply chain not saying
everybody I'm not saying any particular
group of people I'm saying there are
people who really don't get it well we
have been really really lucky our
society is super specialized and we
don't have to like spend all day farming
and doing all this other stuff but it
makes us very spoiled it very makes us
very insular and we don't realize
everything that goes into bringing us
for example our pizza or our pencil or
or milk on the store shelves and it
weakens us and I think that that might
even be a component to men becoming
weaker as well and people not even being
interested in having kids like I wonder
if it's like a hugely overarching
societal problem of ease that's just
what I came up with oh well there's
there's that aspect there's diet there's
chemicals there's also the lowering of
the IQ of children because of lead and
other poisons in our environment there's
there's a lot of things that attributes
to it to the indoctrination centers that
people call schools there's there's so
many different things that contribute to
the destruction of the future of the
United States that it's almost as if
it's being done deliberately to this
point especially financially
economically if you look at what's
Happening Here we are headed towards an
utter disaster we are falling off the
cliff very soon I think we're already
off the cliff but we're still in the
moment where we think it's fun it's not
uh there's going to be where we think
it's fun yeah
and then I think we're moments away from
realizing holy crap there's a lot of
consequences for our uh deliberate
actions that have put us on this
trajectory towards a wall that's that's
all the way down let me just I'll just
add one thing too it's uh like we drove
off the edge of the of the cliff yeah
we're flying through the air and we're
like going we people are all cheering
and screaming and there's a few of us
Jim Cramer's like the economy's doing
better than ever and there's and there's
a few people in the car going guys guys
we're actually gonna start falling down
the cliff into that Rocky crevasse and
then Sienna you got Oliver Darcy or
whatever he's in the car with us he goes
actually falling into the cross is a
good thing it's a good thing
uh we can make the train fly that's what
I'm focusing on right now so get on
board good luck in yeah it's gonna take
some some effort but what do you think
John well I would you know you made me
think of modern monetary policy you know
like you can just we could we could we
can we can uh spend our way out of it
right sure yeah oh yeah that works great
for our families and I I have to believe
that they're like high level banker and
financial dudes that are like working
around the Federal Reserve and they're
printing all of this money they're well
it's digital so they're typing all this
money and then as soon as the like some
of these bankers get the money they
immediately convert it into something
else they're like the money and then
they're buying crypto they're buying
silver they're buying gold they're
buying land and they're buying it in
other countries yes because I'll tell
you this man
if you if look right what what a Bitcoin
fell from like 60 was that 68 and it
fell to like 43 it's the holidays so a
lot of people expected this if you know
what's going on with crypto but even now
you know everyone's I had people
imagining me like oh was were you
talking all this good stuff about crypto
saying it was going to be all big and
I'm like dude I bought it at like a
couple Grand you know I'm like of course
it drops down but I'm I'm I'm happy
you know when when everything started
getting bad you know around last year I
started saying I didn't want to be
holding on to US Dollars and so I
decided not to I decided to just you
know try and invest in the company as
much as I can get the equipment the
company needs as fast as possible
prices have gone way up we have a guitar
because we're recording a bunch of new
music and we got Pete perrotta formerly
of The Offspring who's working with us
big fan awesome super excited and um
I've got a standard uh Mexican
Telecaster it's a guitar
and I bought that thing for like 450
bucks brand new and now I have another
standard uh Mexican Telly and it was
twice the price and it's only been I
think like four or five years or
whatever the prices doubled I went to a
guitar store and the guy told me that if
you order a guitar today it's going to
take you uh 18 months or whatever to get
it it's becoming harder and harder to
get things and people are are not
realizing it because it's a ripple
effect there there was some leftists who
tweeted like this is a luxury problem I
can't remember who it was she was like
all the rich people are just complaining
because their luxuries are more
expensive it's like yo milk is up but
yeah are you listening to the warnings
so we're at the industry we're in an
industry professional level it's really
difficult to get things like the
Internet it's really difficult to get
specialty equipment for it it's
ridiculously expensive because we're
trying to get the best of the best to
run a business so we are seeing the the
problems we're trying to get more space
built at the studio instead we have to
get a different Studio we can't move the
HVAC because the the materials we need
for it aren't being shipped in they
don't exist as a regular person
complaining about whether they can get
HVAC materials no but what happens next
it's a ripple effect we got a bunch of
Articles popping up saying next year
sticker shock is going to cause the an
apocalypse for the for for middle class
workers when they when they see the
price jump January 1st I think it is
General Mills raising the price on all
cereals by 20 that means if you're like
I got a budget for cereal box of cereal
for my kids is five bucks now it's going
to be six bucks your budget's all off
and then maybe one dollar right there
but it adds up across the board because
it's gonna affect the grains are going
to affect everything of course
I opened up a bag of chips last night
and it was like a third of a bag of
chips of worth of chips it was so sad
yeah so much empty space in that bag oh
shrink flight should be that way go that
people are posting photos of when they
like I bought a box of waffles then came
back and the box is Tiny yeah to be fair
though Americans eat way too much true
yeah we went when we were in Texas we
went to a diner and the plate they gave
me was like a trough I was like I don't
I don't I can't eat this you know I love
it I have to bring it home every time
every time I go out in any kind of
restaurant I'm like give me it just give
me it to go anyway I'm gonna take it
home eat it later I hate wasting food
yeah to your point you know this is one
of the craziest things I'm trying to
wrap my head around you know because a
lot of these the lockdown policies that
that we experienced well all over the
world but certainly here in America
right that led to a lot of obesity I
mean the numbers are actually astounding
I don't have them in front of me but but
like and that is actually the thing
aside from age and having some
comorbidities that that actually makes
you way more susceptible to covet
that's that's nuts yeah is it like um
confirm that at least like fat cells is
that like an official scientific
narrative now I just saw that and I just
saw that headline I haven't read the
article yet I I have to look at it looks
I mean you read something like that
you're like I think I'm gonna take a
really close look at this before I just
accept it there was an article from last
year where they said that they tested uh
ice cream tested positive for covid in
China and they had to recall this ice
cream it was in the ice cream so I
thought okay maybe it lives in animal
fat
um but I've never seen another article
about it never saw it confirmed or
denied it just appeared in Newsweek and
then it was gone I'd say that even if it
doesn't live in fat cells it's probable
that obesity weakens the immune system
enough in every way that it's enough but
they're trying to figure out why they're
trying to figure out why I will I will
just say sugar is the devil that's right
and get it out of there yep you don't
need it anymore it's bad don't I'm doing
keto right now too man yeah I'm trying
to trying to lose a little bit I just
got I got hit with the sugar in here a
little bit but
there was nothing there was nothing to
it for me I I didn't care I was I was
skating you know every day and then one
day I just accidentally only ate you
know high fat meat and cheese had like
avocados for breakfast and then I had
heavy cream in my coffee and then I was
like I just keep doing it whatever and
then I ended up losing a bunch of weight
and I've just been feeling better and
better see I can't do the diets where
you're like just do this much or to eat
less or like this is really simple no
carbs that's easy I can do that right
it's not no carbs yeah yeah yeah it's
very yeah no of course of course because
it you'd be insane also vegetables if
someone was a conspiracy theorist and if
there were Central controllers out there
you know what would be better than
having a disease out there that Kohl's
the population especially the people who
eat the most and the most elderly that
don't work don't produce anything and uh
don't uh and you have to give a pension
to what better way to slim the fat
literally and figuratively if you were a
central controller hypothetically
theoretic quickly if you were doing that
thanks for checking out this segment
from the timcast IRL podcast if you want
to watch live you can check out this
channel Monday through Friday at 8 pm
and don't forget to smash that like
button subscribe to this Channel and if
you want more unfiltered and uncensored
content with all of these guests go to
timcast.com and become a member all of
these guests you know and love in
exclusive segments on our website where
we are unrestricted in what we talk
about so you'll definitely not want to
miss it thanks for hanging out we'll see
you all next time